mc écoute pas par marc tu ses marques
que maintenant moment travaillent dehors
et c'est papa qui va s'occuper beaucoup
de marques maintenant et tu vois marque
par exemple aujourd'hui
eh ben c'est papa qui va faire manger
marc tu veux alors papa c'est pas comme
maman parce que papa lui il va profiter
de ce repas pour apprendre plein de
choses à marcq
alors on va commencer
duvoid marque ça c'est une assiette et
marque
il va manger de la purée avec du jambon
non pas son beau parce qu'en bon jambon
voilà ma ont fait pas plus avec la merde
c'est pas preuve un petit garçon propre
ma mais ils mangent avec cuillère tiens
voilà qui y est ma cuillère ne sert pas
balancer purée dans l'oeil de cette ag
idioma il moment et aurait donné une
correction mais papa c'est pas pareil
parce que papa lui il compte sur
intelligence de marc demarcq y mange
très bien avec lui hier ben c'est très
bien elle sera jalousie ce moment ils m
ont fait pas de la bouche même de pure
et emma est apathie moment qu'il fallait
manger pour fermer
bush père mais il ya une autre chose
marque il faut pas essayer d'avaler
tranches de jambon entière comme tu le
fais
non parce que estomac de marque c'est un
petit sac alors élastique du petit quand
même ça sera pas oui mais ne recrache
pas n'engage pas non wouah du lait pour
faire passer non mais le cas pas le lait
dans la brousse comme ça qu'a fait le
job tant pis si ton gros pour petit sam
hamad à balma normalement tu va pas
pleurer pas pleurer surtout la bouche
ouverte
non c'est pas beau à voir alors tu y
apprendre la vie mais pour cacher tout
ça allait cache cache cache c'est plus
propre nom
ma non tu vas pas tu sais pas et perd
lui m'a pas aidé et pas crié papa
horreur des crimes à barret ou pas il va
balancer pure est fauché dans la gueule
de mars à parrainer matar est où tu vas
morfler reflet d'un mot d'argot que
marche ne comprend pas ne peut pas s'en
fout écoute chérie c'est pas de ma faute
c'est encore lui qui a commenté